it's nine o'clock this is sky news
welcome to our new show beth rigby
interviews and as you can see it's a bit
different tonight because i'm on
assignment in india with the prime
minister and earlier today i interviewed
him about partygate and the prospects of
more fines we'll have all of that coming
up soon but before that let me tell you
about what else we have on the show
[Music]
fighting for her father's freedom the
daughter of a british u.s national
jailed in iran tells me her family feels
abandoned roxanne tabas claims the
foreign office promised her father
morad's release along with nazaneen
zagari ratcliffe last month
so
what went wrong during the deal to
release those british nationals and can
this family ever be reunited
and i'll be interviewing the former
health secretary matt hancock in poster
in the start of the pandemic part of a
hugely successful vaccine rollout but
forced to resign after breaking his own
social distancing guidelines will boris
johnson still have his back in if more
party gate fines emerge
those interviews recorded back in
westminster but here in india the prime
minister has traveled 4 000 miles
thinking perhaps he could escape
partygate but back home there have been
issues today in parliament and this is
what he had to say about all of that
crucially he told me he feels he has
nothing to hide
prime minister i do want to ask you
about indian trade but i'm going to have
to ask you about events at home because
things are very live and very difficult
for you
back in london
why did you perform a huge u-turn today
and decide to drop an attempt to delay a
vote about investigating you by the
privileges standards committee
the most important thing is that we
allow the investigation by the by the
met to continue and i think all other uh
and to conclude and then for sue grey to
uh to make her her final uh report and
um
what i decided
uh is that you know if
the opposition really want to focus on
this and they and
it's very important that nobody should
say that we're trying to avoid scrutiny
and i don't want to avoid scrutiny and
um so why don't you try and block the
vote because i what i don't want to do
is to have
um
endless discussion about this when we
don't know the conclusion of the uh the
labour management doesn't
doesn't start the inquiry until the
investigation is concluded so that is
completely logical just we just need it
get the thing concluded if people want
further conversation about that i don't
want to uh in any way to to dissuade
them i happen to think uh that
you know i've made my point i i
apologize for
very much for
uh the fpn that i received um we've
taken steps to change things in uh in
number 10. um but we need to focus
frankly on the things that matter to the
people of this country uh directly now
okay how to how to make sure that we
continue to come on
what i felt was people were saying look
this looks as though we're trying to uh
to stop stuff
coming out i didn't want that i didn't
want people to be able to say that i
don't want this thing endlessly to uh to
go on but if you know i i have
absolutely nothing frankly uh to hide
here nothing
no let's let's but if if that is what
the um the opposition want to to talk
about that's fine okay what i want to
talk about is the uh
point of this trip uh which is
and we'll come on to that steve baker
who is a key ally of yours helped you
get elected a key brexiteer said in the
comments today the pm it should now be
long gone he should know the gig is up
that must hurt well you know
steve faker i i understand
uh people's feelings i i don't think
that that's the right thing to do i
think we've got to wait for the
conclusion of the uh of the report and
and perhaps i could say a bit more then
that's what that's what i said in the
meantime what i what i would like to do
is get on uh with taking the country
forward making sure that we uh deal with
the immediate problems that we face and
i i'm particularly proud of some of the
things that
you said that you have nothing to hide
but you are also under investigation for
up to five events you're involved in
up to five more events
i know you can't but you might have more
fines you do accept that beth you're
going to have to wait okay conclusion of
the report when i ask you yes in the
meantime i promise to get on to that
i think people always hear well you did
promise and i did promise to get on with
the subsidies the bbc did seven minutes
on parts again and i'm sure i haven't
done as much as that one
this isn't the kind of competition to
see you can do more why didn't you why
didn't you get onto the subject of the
trip i would just like to ask you this
you said on the plane last night when i
said are there any circumstances in
which you might feel that your position
is unsustainable or you might have to
resign
you said nothing springs to mind i said
to you and i'm sure you could you could
you could uh elaborate some for the
benefit of your viewers but i think what
i want to do you could you know extend
price on what i want to do
is get on with uh the the job uh which i
was elected to do you say and and that's
what we're doing but you also that's
what we're focused on but you also said
that you wanted to get on with things
that matter to voters do you think that
the issues around rule breaking at
number 10 doesn't matter to them
i apologize for uh for the things i
apologize deeply for the things we've
got wrong i came to the house on on
tuesday made a two-hour statement i did
another uh half an hour or more i think
on
on wednesday uh
i believe there's been a big debate on
it today uh but we've got to get on uh
with the priorities of the of the people
that's what we're doing and you think
there's a storm in a westminster tea
couple those are your words
so you don't think it's that you do
think
i think of course i think it's i think
it's serious and it's important but i
also think that we have massive issues
that uh people expect us to address and
i think that people want us to get on
uh with the job of taking the country
forward uh making sure that we attract
further investment and this country is
attracting record investment right now
it's a fantastic thing to see and you're
just as a result of this uh trip to
india you've got
just today you've got investment worth
yeah uh a billion billion pounds uh
producing eleven thousand dollars
tomorrow tomorrow what we're what we're
signing yes because you've probably
talked about step if you let me finish
this um you just to be clear you you
said about the fine you had and the
apology uh that you didn't realize that
you had broken rules that it was a
genuine mistake to be clear
at all times even the bring your own
bottle event
in number 10 garden on may the 20th
at all times did you always think in
every single event you were not breaking
the rules so you never thought you broke
the rules
you're asking me to comment well you
said you had nothing to hide and i'm
going to comment at the end of that
investigation i've been very very clear
about that what i was saying is i don't
i don't uh
shrink at all from having uh more
parliamentary scrutiny if that's what
the opposition want what i want to do is
i want to do
indeed but what i want to do is focus on
the things that matter i think to uh the
the future of the country uh and that is
making sure that we uh help people with
the cost of their energy you accept your
mp's are unhappy then
so that's your those are your words uh i
want to get on and deal with uh the
priorities one more one more question
then i want to ask you about the trade
deal you you've had a torrid time sorry
um how
do you really believe that the party
that the country will allow you
to to lead the conservative party into
the next general election right here
right now you're absolutely determined
to do that of course i am and what what
i'm determined to do is to make sure
that we continue with our agenda which
is to uh unite and level up don't forget
this is the the government that gets
done some very very difficult things uh
we deliver the fastest vaccine rollout
in europe we came out of covert faster
than anybody else we got brexit done and
when people said it was impossible and
we've led the world in uh standing up to
aggression i think even you would
concede beth standing up to aggression
uh in uh
finally and and we will get on we will
get on with that work and since you now
come to the point of the trip thank you
very much uh let me just remind you that
uh that uh what we hope to do
is a uh a free trade deal with uh with
india uh by the autumn i think it has
great potential you've already got
things like
uk medicines
uk uk food
agreements have been done in advance
apples uh you'd be thrilled to know uh
are going to be able to come to this uh
market in a way they haven't been able
to come uh before uh
and and and much more besides there is a
huge amount that unites the uk and india
give me one example uh the the very
vaccines i just mentioned
are a classic example of collaboration
between the uk
and india 1.5 billion people
around the world vaccinated thanks to
kobe shield which was basically a uh an
anglo england indian collaboration prime
minister thank you so much thank you
boris johnson there well the other
interviews for the show i recorded back
in london coming up fighting to bring
her father home we hear from the
campaigner roxanne tavis who says her
father morad who's been imprisoned by
the iranian authorities has now been
abandoned by the uk government
[Music]
welcome back in march the uk repaid a
long-standing debt to tehran paving the
way for the release of nazanin zagari
ratcliffe and anushay of shori from
prison in iran but the plain home had a
passenger missing the environmentalist
morad tabes his family say a pledge to
bring morad back to the uk was broken by
the foreign office now they say they
feel abandoned i've been speaking to
roxanne tabas morad's daughter she's not
just fighting for his release but also
her mother who's been banned from
traveling out of tehran during our
interview she told me about the toll the
ordeal's taken on her family and her
fears for her father roxanne fuzzy
thanks for coming on the show and
spending some time with us i want to
talk to you about your dad morad tabes
who is still imprisoned in iran
can you tell us about your father's
situation he's still in even
in the prison he
was meant to be on a furlough which we
still haven't seen come to fruition and
it's been now five weeks
since the others returned so i think
he's feeling quite abandoned and and a
little bit hopeless i think so there was
a deal and you hoped your dad murad
would come home with nazaneen sakai
ratcliffe and anushay shuri who are both
now back in the uk but your dad has
ended up back
in evan prison where they were both
incarcerated as well how did he end up
in this situation he was in iran for his
wildlife conservation efforts
and he he got picked up in january 2018.
um
but i think it it came as a huge shock
and surprise to all of us because
i mean he was there to to help really um
and it was it was definitely something i
think hit all of us quite hard we felt
that there must have been a mistake or
the the messaging wasn't right but it it
was really
difficult to stomach um
and it's been ongoing so it's been over
four years now and how did you discover
your dad had been arrested
uh we got a call from from a family
member
to say that they just heard
that he'd been taken and
and my mom was put on a travel ban and
she's still there as well so your dad
was in iran was arrested your mum was
there with him and is now on a travel
ban and your dad has been in the same
prison that nazanina and nushay were in
and he's been there since 2018 or 2019.
how does your dad sustain
himself in there keep himself sane
do you get to talk to him
he's always been a very positive person
so i think he
tries to look for any sort of light if
you will that he can
um
but
but yeah i think anybody in those
circumstances will will struggle to
to have hope really
um
it's
it's a difficult one because
any time we've communicated to him it's
been through my mom and she'll put two
phones on speaker next to each other and
we kind of shout across
but my dad's
the ultimate dad so he never lets on
that he's having a bad day or that he's
not feeling well he's always
asking about his children and how we are
and if there's any news that we want to
share with him and
and just to share i love ease and i
misuse and we're here for each other
really but he's not very well is he your
dad no
he had cancer
some time ago and had quite a lot of
health complications coming out of it
and a lot of those still require ongoing
treatment and monitoring so so we do
worry for him has he still got cancer
well we don't know um we don't really
have a way to
to find out really following the release
of nazinina nanushi and he found out
that they'd come back he was meant to be
on furlough and was taken back to the
prison
and on his return to the prison he
decided that he wanted the uk to know
that he was still there and suffering
and and that he
he felt betrayed and abandoned so
he started a hunger strike that went on
nine days but i think it was really
difficult for him even to to give it up
because it was his one sense of
i think control in a way as his child i
imagine you're not sure if he's still
ill
he's not having any treatment then he
goes on a hunger strike i mean you must
be desperately worried about him
we are um but we also we have faith in
him and and his decisions so we wanted
to be supportive but with more days that
passed we thought you know what we
that's why we have to be public now we
can't stay quiet anymore your dad was
put on farley when nazini and nushay
were released which was
meant to be that he was allowed to
return home
and then 48 hours after they landed he
was sent back to prison and he
started a hunger strike which you asked
him to stop
you were led to believe that your dad
would get released as part of that same
deal
why did you believe that and what
happened
the the foreign office is i mean when i
say they the foreign office
told us they assured us that my dad and
mom would be a part of any deal that
they were constructing uh for the other
two hostages um we
were short at every turn that he wasn't
going to be left behind that he would be
a part of that
um and and we believe them when did you
discover that your dad wasn't part
of that deal that you've been told he
was part of we found out in the press
when nazineen and anusha were on the
plane
so when it when it went live that they
were coming back
we found out with the rest of the world
through the media
i think the closest
feeling i could describe is probably
betrayal
we had four years of having faith in the
government and
and they abandoned us and they left him
behind
so you learned about it by reading the
press with everyone else what did you do
then
uh well that's when we had to make a
different decision we'd always been
advised by the foreign office to stay
quiet and out of the media so that
the negotiations wouldn't be negatively
impacted and
and we decided at that juncture maybe we
need to change tact because the other
two families went public and they got
their family members back that must have
been
i imagine quite personally hard that you
had put your faith in the foreign office
that you hadn't as
sherry anusha's
wife and obviously richard with nazaneen
that you hadn't
publicly campaigned although you'd
clearly been working very hard to get
your dad's release was that really hard
that you thought
you'd made a
a mistake yeah uh it was but at the time
we
i don't think anyone can be prepared to
be presented with this kind of situation
but we thought it's the foreign office
it's england
surely they know
and you know we weren't in a position to
to go against
their advice because they in theory
would have known better than anyone what
about your mp as well because tulip
sadiq had campaigned very vocally
alongside richard what about your mp
uh felicity bucknan uh
my because my home is in notting hill so
i'm i'm kensington and chelsea
um
i think it's
it's difficult because
i'm his daughter so he technically
isn't her constituent um
but again everything gets funneled back
to the foreign office anyway
um
so we're
at this point we're just kind of hoping
that
liz trusts and and boris johnson will
really
actually keep up with the promise they
made to us and and follow through on the
deal that they presented to us you
talked about your dad um
and his citizenship because he has a
triple citizenship he is british
american
and iranian he has three uh
nationalities
has that been a hindrance do you think
in trying to get him
released
initially we we didn't think it would be
because
we would have thought that having uk us
you'd be in
i mean you'd be fully covered in theory
um
and
now
the answer that we're getting from the
foreign office is that his situation's
more complicated because he's also
american and the iranians want to see
him as american
um
it's a bit difficult to stomach because
it's
they can't decide that
you know if england
knows who their citizens are my dad was
born here he's british
uh they have his birth certificate who's
born in hammersmith hospital he's he's
from here
um
so
so i don't i don't accept that excuse
really anushay said when i spoke to him
and cheri said this his wife as well
that because of the dual citizenship
because they had spent parts of their
lives in iran that when they dealt with
the foreign office sometimes they felt
that people questioned their britishness
and their citizenship is that how you
have felt about your dad as well that
he's not quite british enough for them
to care enough i think it's something
that you always consider
my dad's american citizenship is from
naturalization he he went to university
there and decided to settle down there
with my mom
but i don't think that makes him any
less
british nazanin and nushay
they both care very deeply about your
father and about his case anusha
uh was friends with your dad in heaven
prison he spoke
about how he can't be at peace until
your dad is also released and nazanin
who i think grew close to your mother in
tehran
uh also invited you to her first press
conference to publicize your dad's case
have they been a great source of
strength for you and your family nazanin
spent quite a lot of time actually with
my mom when she was on furlough and they
grew really close
and and richard really forged the way
for us here um it's really
the murky waters to navigate it's it's
challenging because you're carrying this
huge weight with you and everything you
do and say
has an impact in in a different way in
different scenarios
um but it was richard and nazanin that
chose to include us in their celebration
to help us highlight my dad's case
and and they've always been really
encouraging about going public um
and they've always invited us to be
included on that um but because we were
trying to follow the advice we were
given we were always very careful and
and stayed away from that but when they
found out that we were more open to it
they were the first ones to really help
us
kind of step out of the shadows and and
into the light and and to help really
your mum is also
now in iraq you're both your parents
you're the eldest of three
siblings and it's kind of fallen on you
to publicize the case you've also got
your own life and your own job i mean it
must be
pretty hard going isn't it
it is uh but i guess
you find strength in in quite broken
places and you surround yourself with
people that that can hold you up when
when you don't feel like you can stand
really so i've been really
lucky i think that's why we're we're
here today and and all the other press
interviews and things we've done it's
been there is that fear that if we don't
stay public and we don't
step forward that they'll they'll forget
him and he'll be abandoned there for
longer than he already has been your dad
is
sentenced to 10 years in prison and he's
what now in his late 60s yes 66.
presumably
your feeling is he just
can't be there
for that long you have to get him out we
do and
and i think it's not even just physical
health for anybody in that scenario it's
mental health as well
um and they're both there my my mom's
been sat waiting
for ages and if her travel ban was meant
to be lifted the way his furlough was
meant to happen
we still don't understand why she hadn't
been then put on that plane so we could
at least see her for a few days she
would have gone back anyway because
her partner her love of her life is
there she she wait for him forever they
remember their high school sweethearts
you don't forget somebody like that in
your life
what's your message then to liz truss
bring them home
they they promised us and
you know if if nothing else they
they should have upheld the furlough
that they publicly celebrated and
announced because
you know if it if it was decided then it
should happen it's been five weeks
and nothing's changed there's been no
update of any substantive background of
any sort and
you know we'd really like some answers
but also i'm really tired of words
we'd like to see some action now and
just finally do you think the u.s
government
can help get your dad out
i think they they've been working on it
just as hard the state department and
foreign office work in tandem but again
he this is home to him this is who he is
so
and that was who promised us the results
the uk
said to us that he was going to be in
the deal
and do you think he do you think you'll
get him back
i can't think about if i don't get him
back because
he he was
i mean he is he it's you can't even say
past tense or present tense anymore
because it's so
complicated but
when it's your dad it's your dad there's
there's no love like the love of a
daughter or a son has for a father
stay with us because coming up next
what lessons were learned in the
pandemic the former health secretary
matt hancock joins me in the studio to
discuss regrets what he thinks the
government got right and what the future
might hold for him
[Music]
it's over two years since the first
coronavirus lockdown since then more
than a hundred and seventy thousand
people in the uk have lost their lives
to covid
lessons we were told would be learned
and we'd be better prepared for future
pandemics but how possible is that with
an nhs on its knees matt hancock the
health secretary who was challenged with
the biggest crisis that's faced the nhs
since it was created history and an
upcoming inquiry into the pandemic will
judge how well he handled that challenge
but earlier he joined me in the studio
to discuss regrets what he thinks the
government got right and what the future
might hold for him matt hancock thanks
so much for coming
on the show uh we're just back from the
easter holidays and i don't know about
you but when i was on my easter break it
finally felt like life was back to
normal properly back to normal
is the kovid pandemic finally over do
you think
yes in this country
the cove is obviously endemic
meaning that it's everywhere and
lots of people catch it
but you know every week they publish the
statistics of how many people have got
antibodies to protect you from covert
and it's now over 99
and
that's that's great and it means that we
can have what is essentially a free
existence here
is but it's not over everywhere around
the world in fact i think you know one
of the really shocking things
as is watching how some of the countries
that went for a zero-covered strategy at
the start
are now in real trouble
negotiating their way to being you know
part of the international community
again the reason i'm asking you is
because for the
nhs the sort of fallout as you were
saying is still quite extreme
for the nhs i had a look at the stats
before
we sat down on april the 11th there were
301 deaths and 40 000
cases
people on waiting lists for treatment
record levels of 6.2 million a and e
waiting times worse since recalls began
trolley weights at record levels i mean
i bet you're glad that this isn't your
job to fix this anymore huh um
and crucially the number of vacant
hospital
uh beds in england's lower than at any
time since the start of the crisis and
you know that's a
key measure of resilience yeah i mean if
you had a close family member that
needed nhs treatment against that
backdrop would you be would you be
worried about that
well
i think
that
fixing this is clearly critical
and there's a plan in place the
government put a plan in place
um
to tackle this backlog
but you know
a year ago thinking about how to tackle
the backlog post the
uh the the pandemic was a priority and
then we had omicron over last christmas
and so it's obviously really serious and
it will take time to get through that
backlog
of you know things that were postponed
so you know that's why i said the
pandemic's over but we're still with the
hangover and the impact on the nhs and
remember the people who work in the nhs
are tired as well they must be so tired
um so so there's a big you know that's a
it's a big challenge they're probably so
tired that when you say as a former
health sector it's over they might even
feel a bit irritated by that because
they might be thinking it's really not
over for us we're dealing with this
still day in day out well the
consequences are still there absolutely
but the that's the difference between a
disease being you know pandemic
affecting everybody in our normal lives
and just and endemic as a bad disease
you know another flu let's look back
briefly on the pack you've talked about
this loads as an inquiry you've given
evidence to selectees i don't want to go
on and on about it but you are here yeah
and you did live through it and you did
do a lot of decision making around it
yeah um on the positive
uh the vaccine task force has been
widely praised led by kate bingham you
actually by the select committee were
praised for personally taking charge of
the testing system although they were
critical of test and trace
there's some of the couple of successes
what do you think were the biggest
mistakes when you reflect back on it
what do you think i wish i had done that
differently
well i think there's quite a lot of
things that we need to learn from
both from the good and the bad so it's
really important to learn from the
things that went well as well uh it's a
bit like um after a football match you
know the team that wins uh you win 2-1
and everyone says wow that was an
amazing performance everything went
right well yeah i accepted that you let
go you let a goal in so let's learn from
the successes as well we can learn from
the vaccination program uh getting
external expertise in yeah from
including from business from
academia and and clinicians that team
absolutely brilliant also completely
giving them their head and saying
we want you to buy from around the world
we want you to and basically you know
the price is less important because the
saving to the economy of getting this
right is so big so there were a couple
of big learning points uh from the
successes
um and then but there were areas that
were uh that were problematic
what's your biggest regret well
one of the things i point to is some of
the
some of the rules that were put in place
the way that they were interpreted on
the ground
um and that the restrictions you mean
yeah so for instance do you remember
early in
2020 during the first lockdown
um
there were funerals that took place
without their loved ones yes you know
you regret that i i do because it and so
that was incredibly upsetting
um
and that was because
of
it it wasn't the intention but it was
the consequence of the rules and we then
we saw that happen and we changed it but
nevertheless you've you know you've got
to be
your biggest personal regret well that
was that was one of them um but you know
the thing is in it managing something
as big as a pandemic
you know
you're never going to get every decision
right your aim is to get most decisions
right and especially when something is
genuinely unprecedented and
one thing i did want to ask you
specifically on was was the issue of
care homes i know you've been asked a
lot about it but was that is that
something now in retrospect
you wish you had done differently well
discharging people
into care homes without being tested no
i'm going to give you a different
explanation of what happened and i've
thought obviously thought about this a
lot well you've been asked i mean and it
will be a big focus of the inquiry it
will and so what the inquiry what the um
evidence shows
is that the number of infections that
got into care homes from people being
discharged from hospital was very very
low
so there's been a i've got here an
estimated 25 000 people would discharge
from hospitals into care homes without
getting a test well that's when that's
the height of the epidemic in the spring
2020 yeah so that's that's when there
weren't tests widely available before
we'd managed to scale up the testing
yeah um
the
that must be a regret though muslim
isn't it well if you let me explain what
actually happened rather than what is
the narrative around this because this
is somewhere where the narrative is
wrong and it's really important we
correct it and learn the right lessons
not the wrong ones
so around two percent of infections got
into care homes through that discharge
process part of the reason is that
because there wasn't a test everyone was
put into isolation
so i can't
you know if you can come up with a
better option of what to do with people
who need to leave hospital and go back
to their care home you know um putting
everyone in isolation that was the
policy now the level of isolation will
have been different in different care
homes um
the challenge in terms of where the
infection came from
is that everybody in the community lots
of people were catching covid and
inevitably working in people worked in
care homes but i didn't want to go and
stand on that podium and effectively um
say that i'm terribly sorry this came
from the staff who live in the community
going not it came from a mix didn't it
well so they've they've done the
analysis and found actually the big
change that we made that really affected
this
and meant that the the likelihood of
catching covert in a care home was so
much lower in the second wave
was that we stopped people moving staff
moving between between him and that
actually was a much much bigger impact
so this comes back to the lessons piece
yes of course one of the lessons is you
know don't discharge people who haven't
been tested you know what i'm going to
answer the question and then you can ask
your next one rather than you aren't
finishing them i thought you were having
a conversation but okay well i'd love to
have a conversation but the conversation
involves listening to the answer my
question right your question right so
okay so the the point is this right
that the
um the the
policy of discharge involved the pro
everybody going into isolation because
we didn't know whether they had covered
um
the big impact
that really protected uh care homes was
when we said you can't work in more than
one care home yeah
so for the one of the lessons we need to
learn is you put that policy in place
right yeah and then the other
in terms of discharges is you must have
a testing system ready to go because we
had to build that from scratch so those
are the two lessons so you
that's fine so you do agree that that
was a mistake to allow people to be
discharged from hospital without being
tested no because you're saying it's
both things no i'm saying it's that we
didn't have the tests in place
so the lesson on that front is have the
tests be ready with the testing system
ready to go because and the reason i'm
i'm sort of um really clear on this
point and may you know emphatic about it
is that um
leaving people
in hospital longer than they need to be
in hospital is also bad for them
and bad for the people who otherwise
need to be in hospital
so the discharge policy had a had an
important merit behind it yeah so
so what so what i really think on care
homes and what i hope is coming over is
that is that there is a narrative about
what went wrong in care homes um
fundamentally the narrative is wrong
and part of the job of the inquiry and
part of the lessons learning exercise
yes is to learn the right lessons
including from things that didn't go as
well as they could have done yeah but
that was the narrative we heard from a
lot of care home bosses wasn't it that
people were being discharged and
bringing this is the point this is why
we're having the discussion because um
because it's actually important to
listen to the science and look at the
evidence and learn the lessons from the
science and the evidence
not say well because that was on the
front page of the newspapers at the time
it must have been true because that
isn't actually what happened the main
thing that happened is that i was the
infection
we could spend a long a lot of time
talking about this because dominic
cummings said that you told the pm
anyone going into a care home would be
tested
uh even if you disputed that you did
tell the public there was a protective
ring and then people found that people
were going that hadn't been tested i
take your we're going to talk about
staff okay we can go through i'm just
saying is it
you seem to be saying that i'm i'm
saying that i think it's not well no i'm
not i'm saying no so the point about dom
cummings is you know you're wrong um so
that's not important um the point what
is important is that we know as a
society next time there's a pandemic
because there will be one we know how
best to protect people in care homes
and if we learn the wrong lessons then
we will not do it next time as well as
possible and the thing i really care
about
is that the person in my shoes next time
has like a manual on the on you know
that's a testing regime yeah but also
more broadly than that has a manual on
the shelf that says you know this is how
you do it because we didn't have that at
all yeah um except in some specific
areas all of which will come out in the
inquiry which i think will be useful for
everyone to get get the facts out there
yeah um let's move on though because i
would like to talk to you more about
that but i'm going to run out of time
okay so
i want to talk to you about cover
casting a long shadow in other ways yeah
and and specifically at the moment on
the career of a prime minister
who's now being fined by the police for
attending a cavid event he could uh an
event that was deemed as breaching uh
the rules and he could receive more
penalties as you know he's under
investigation for other events and
there's been a number of fines for
people within downward street and
government
but you don't believe the pm should
resign uh
over this why not
because i think that when you're looking
at
who should be the prime minister you've
got to look in the round you've got to
look at the big picture
on kovid i think that we've got the big
calls right
um and there's a war
and the prime minister is leading the
international response to vladimir putin
and so you've got to look forward and
you've got to take everything into
account
does that does your piscion stay the
same however many finds he gets or
however much the public and the polling
uh reflects and anger in amongst the
public does this
of course i understand that anger and
the prime minister's apologized
and you've got to look at where we are
now and what's happening now in the
world and you know we're in this phase
of history where you know big things
keep coming along you know
no longer no we just sorted brexit when
the pandemic hit and then you're the pat
we were just coming out of the pandemic
when the war started and that we've got
to make sure i was like what is in the
national interest you're that is what
matters right now and you are speaking
as a politician and a loyal lieutenant
to the the prime minister
but it must resonate with you
on a personal level too because
you did resign you
yeah had a relationship with someone it
became
public in a way that was obviously
difficult for you and your families
you were found to have broken guidelines
you resigned
do you feel bitter looking back about
being exposed in that way and forced to
resign and you don't
feel that there's a contradiction in the
prime minister's behavior how do you
feel about it on a personal level now no
i i wasn't uh forced by anybody to
resign i chose to resign
and the
you know in a way it makes
makes the point more powerfully
that you in the prime minister you have
to look at who is
best placed right now to be leading this
country with the challenges that we face
and
especially you know
the response to
vladimir putin
is the single most important
international thing going on right now
and responding to the cost of the main
crisis domestically and on the formula i
mean people would also say that
prime ministers have been changed at
times during war we aren't actually
directly at war in the uk but the
promise is
some of your colleagues would disagree
with that well people disagree in
politics that's the nature of this thing
you know that's in fact in fact i'd
argue that in the democracy uh the
disagreement is the point uh and some of
our um opponents strategically who think
that you should have an autocracy and
not have disagreement don't get the
point that this cacophony of debate
isn't a weakness it's a strength it's
the point of politics so of course
people disagree with me but that but
that's how you feel but that how i feel
about it is you've got to look what is
in the national interest is you know
essentially vladimir zolensky's closest
international ally the guy who has
played an absolutely leading role in
ensuring the strategic response to putin
is not to split the west which is what
putin wanted and i think expected but to
unite the uh the west um and
you know most of the rest of the world
can i come back to your to your
situation because you
you had these photos leaked of you and
gina who you're now
in in a relationship with
and the information commissioner's
office has said there's not enough
evidence to prosecute the people
suspected of leaking that footage
how i mean it was in your private office
i mean this was security how do you feel
about that do you just want it is it
just done now yeah i've said everything
i'm ever going to say on that subject so
do do you want them to be prosecuted you
just i'm just i'm just yeah
i'm just absolutely not going there
you're not going to go that okay
and matt hancock to finish off
you came into parliament in 2010 you
became a minister i remember in 2012.
you were in the cabinet by 2018
and then you had
this massive bump in the road for your
career that wasn't just political but
also personal
did you sort of think about just packing
it in and
and doing something else and beginning a
new life in a different career rather
like your mentor
george osborne did after 2015 did you
give that some thought well obviously
when something huge happens like that
you think about
you know you think about everything
across the board
um
but
the other thing is you know i've got a
job to do representing my
constituents you know and i love doing
that and i've been able to spend far
more time on it in the last year than i
did
i did before and also
being in parliament is a real privilege
um
you have a platform
to talk about and make changes on areas
you really care about so take the
campaign that i'm running on dyslexia
you know i'm dyslexic
and didn't find out until you're at
university exactly i don't know how you
might you got to oxford based on maths
basically you basically got to oxford
university not knowing that you were
dyslexic yeah but uh thankfully i'm very
good at math so i appreciate how i'm one
of the lucky ones who got through
but still one in five dyslexic kids only
one in five get identified at school and
we've got to change that and the the
department have now uh made some changes
and put out a green paper about this and
so you know that is you know
making change from the back benches on
the subject i really care about
personally affects me
and
i i wasn't able to do because i was in
different ministerial roles in
government and so you know that
you know i love doing that
other former cabinet ministers said to
me after i resigned they said you know
the problem is going to be you've gone
from your time being programmed down to
every five minutes you know sometimes my
lube breaks were programmed into the
diary were your little books actually
written in no really yeah
and then going to having you know a lot
more um freedom in how you use your time
um i've i've really enjoyed that and
i've been able to choose how i spend my
time
one more thing you talked a lot about
the prime minister
and ukraine
um number one you think he'll be the
prime minister by the end of the year
still you don't oh yes i think he'll
leave you you don't think there will be
a confidence vote you don't think your
colleagues might try and unseat him
that's right you don't think that will
happen i do not think that will happen
well matt hancock thank you for coming
on and i imagine i will see you uh back
in cabinet uh certainly before you hit
50 what do you think
i'm just
i'm just i'm just enjoying life on the
back bench all right thank you very much
well that's all for today's show and
later you'll be able to get the beth
rigby interviews podcast with the
highlights of this show and some extra
bits too that'll be on the sky news app
or wherever you get your podcasts
[Music]